nosotros ahora sí vamos a revista de
prensa nuestro estudio está Marta Moya
Marta bienvenida buena mañana de viernes
abrimos nuestra revista empresa en Reino
Unido porque la bbc nos ha hecho ya el
primer spoiler de lo que es esta lista
anual de las 100 mujeres del año y con
pocas dudas No una de ellas
evidentemente sería la primera dama de
Ucrania o Lena selenska quien ha
entrevistado en exclusiva si Raúl buenos
días la lista completa va a salir el 6
de diciembre pero como decimos No pues
Elena zelenska es una de las claras
mujeres que
completan este 2022 Por qué Porque ha
adquirido mucha relevancia pública este
año no al final es una persona que
estaba totalmente detrás de las cámaras
porque ella era guionista mientras
telenski era cómico y trabajaban juntos
pero durante estos nueve meses de guerra
pues por ejemplo la hemos visto
ovacionada en el Capitolio
estadounidense la hemos visto asistiendo
al funeral de Isabel II o se ha reunido
con la primera dama de Estados Unidos
Gil biden en el oeste perdón de Ucrania
también salió por ejemplo en la revista
Book en esta entrevista que la bbc
titula resistiremos Pues es de casi una
hora está hecha en la casa de las
quimeras en kiev en la misma calle donde
celensky ese 26 de febrero llamaba a los
ucranianos a pelear en esta guerra no de
esta que hace lensca que además de la
resiliencia de la guerra y de la
incertidumbre que genera estar corriendo
una maratón y no saber cuántos
kilómetros falta para llegar a la meta
describe además el conflicto como una
visión de dos mundos y que no hay una
Victoria Si no hay O sea si no hay paz
si no hay una victoria ucraniana en este
caso no también detalla cosas más
íntimas y dice que al final la guerra
pues le ha hecho perderse en muchos
momentos familiares y lo trata con
nostalgia en este fragmento que vamos a
ver
Cuándo fue la última vez que usted su
marido el presidente su hija de 18 años
y su hijo de 9 años se sentaron a cenar
juntos
no te puedo dar una fecha exacta pero es
muy raro a día de hoy muy raro apenas
nos vemos los cuatro juntos porque
vivimos separados yo con los niños y mi
marido vive en el trabajo
cuando compartimos algunos breves
momentos no son lo suficiente para
nuestros hijos
quizá echemos más de menos eso que
cualquier otra cosa extrañamos las cosas
sencillas poder sentarnos y hablar tanto
como queramos
hablar de todas las cosas las grandes y
las pequeñas cosas que pasan en nuestra
familia ahora lo hacemos pero por
teléfono o videollamada
estamos constantemente en contacto pero
tener todo el tiempo que quisiéramos no
puede ser Lamentablemente
en estas ocasiones no Marta lo más
simple de la vida lo más cotidiano es lo
que más extraña en unos momentos así no
Así así Bueno vamos a ver también
sigamos con esta tónica porque como
estamos a finales de año otros medios
también ya empiezan a hacer su repaso
por los grandes eventos que han marcado
este 2022 que por supuesto No han sido
pocos la pandemia o sea se quedó corta
no concretamente vamos destacaron en
trabajo de la revista Time Marta donde
el equipo editorial ha hecho un resumen
de este año con 100 fotos y empecemos
con la portada Sí Raúl vamos a destacar
esta portada que titula no fotos del año
imágenes que cambiaron la manera en la
que vemos el mundo y más allá y en ese
más allá se destaca una de estas 100
imágenes que es una de las fotos del
telescopio James web que publicó en
julio en esas primeras imágenes del
universo que nunca antes habíamos visto
ahora entonces vamos a seguir con
algunas estas fotos para hacer un vídeo
viaje por el tiempo a través de esta
foto galería Marta sí porque pues son
100 fotos y por cuestiones de tiempo
evidentemente no podemos hacer un repaso
a todas pero hemos querido destacar 11
no eso sí invitamos a todos los
televidentes a que puedan contemplar
estas imágenes para hacer este viaje por
el tiempo en este repaso de las 11 fotos
que hemos destacado empezamos en sri
lanka que destacamos esta foto del mes
de julio donde las protestas contra el
entonces presidente
condujeron al asalto de la residencia
presidencial por la situación crítica
que vivía el país en ese momento y que
todavía vive en la segunda foto
destacamos un homenaje a La tenista
Serena Williams que le hicieron No en un
vídeo tributo en su despedida en el Us
Open a finales de agosto en la tercera
foto destacamos a unos Cadetes
ucranianos en esa primera clase práctica
de emergencia en un búnker en kiev que
se dio a principios de septiembre en la
cuarta foto destacamos el espacio
Memorial que le dedicaron en Texas a las
19 niños y a las dos profesoras que
murieron en la matanza en Ugalde y
también es un poco el símbolo de las
matanzas que ha habido en Estados Unidos
en estos tiroteos masivos en la quinta
foto que destacamos nos vamos también a
Estados Unidos a las protestas en
Pensilvania contra la decisión de la
Corte Suprema de Estados Unidos de
derogar El aborto a escala Federal en la
también Hablamos de protestas en este
caso en Irán y destacamos esta foto de
octubre cuando se cumplieron los 40 días
por la muerte de masa mini que
recordemos murió bajo custodia policial
después de haber sido detenida por la
policía de la moral por llevar mal
puesto el velo islámico en la séptima
foto destacamos a este momento del
funeral de la periodista palestino
estadounidense sherina buacle cuando las
fuerzas israelíes atacaron a estas
personas que asistían al funeral de la
periodista después de que hubiese sido
presuntamente asesinada por una bala de
la policía Israel en mayo en la octava
foto destacamos el funeral de Isabel II
en Londres que se ve aquí a la imagen
del príncipe George el segundo en la
línea de sucesión en ese traslado del
féretro de su bisabuela la novena foto
destacamos a un padre y a una hija
migrantes en ese tapón del Darién
conecta Colombia con Panamá la décima
foto destacamos el traslado Y esto es
una foto icónica del principio de la
guerra de una mujer embarazada tras el
bombardeo ruso en un hospital materno
infantil en mariupol al sur de Ucrania y
en la onceava foto destacamos el disparo
a quemarropa que sufrió el ex Primer
Ministro japonés sin suave en el mes de
julio mientras daba un mitin público en
las afueras de Japón de Cara a las
elecciones legislativas Marta
rápidamente vamos con el titular de el
New York Times en no el reportaje sobre
la situación precisamente del daría en
30 segundos pero no le dejemos por fuera
sí titula hacia una jungla brutal
pequeños actos de bondad es una foto de
Federico ríos que también está destacado
en estas cien fotos del Time el tapón de
las 100 millas entre Colombia y Panamá
el tapón del Darién 215.000 personas han
cruzado en este último año desde enero
personas venezolanas de Cuba de Perú y
de Ecuador entre otros y destaca este
reportaje de cómo en esta situación tan
crítica y en medio de la selva la gente
totalmente desconocida unas entre otras
se ayudan y tienen gestos de empatía
claro
la solidaridad humana que pocas veces se
ve si no hay situaciones como estas
Marta Gracias como siempre por toda la
información la semana que viene porque
ya es viernes feliz fin de semana más
revista de prensa gracias